can you tell us that story about old
Hollywood how accessible stars were back
in the day um yes the guy who does my
headshots name's Jack Allen dream City
photography Tommy's a great story when
he was a kid he said a lot of the stars
were still listed in the phone book and
one of them was made west and he
actually called Mae West on the phone
and she said what do you want so you
know I want to meet you come by Saturday
so she came making my Saturday Mae
West's apartment and Mae West opens the
door all done up to the nines he never
saw her when she wasn't fully thought
out and she says oh so you want to meet
me you want to meet me bad enough to do
my laundry kid he says yes ma'am so he
didnae West laundry this kid he rode his
bike to Mae West house he got to know
her became her friend and he went with
her to the premiere of her last film
sextet and he told me that she never
went in public without being fully done
up she had an old car from the 30s which
he kept in storage and any time she had
to make a public appearance the car was
brought out shine dusted repaired she
was always may West when she stepped out
in public that's all Hollywood and it's
gone of course
you